ثالثة غير وهذا يعني ان الحرب
ربما تكون خلال الشتاء القادم ان
يمكن ان يجعلها تقفز الى الامام
وتصعد الامور الى حرب عالمية
لكن ما يحدث من اجراءات مؤخرا
والوضع السيئ الذي تمر به روسيا
وصنعت متاجر الكترونية صينية
خاصة ايضا. وبذلك لن تستطيع
تحققت التوقعات ليعيش العالم
اسوأ حال يمكن ان يعيشه البشر مع
للكمبيوتر والتليفونات الذكية
وبدأت باستخدام انظمة خاصة بها
وان تدخل في حرب عصابات في جميع
انحاء البلاد. وهو سيناريو من
اوكرانيا خلال الحرب العالمية
والحقيقة ان في هذه الحرب لا
ما تنفك الصين معلنة بين الحين
والاخر عن وباء جديد. فماذا لو
من شرق وجنوب اوكرانيا في اثناء
قتالها لتمرد اوكراني من الغرب
لاوكرانيا. ويمكن لروسيا ان تخلق
درجة معينة من السيطرة على اجزاء
وهنا اعلنت بكين خمسين مليون
كمبيوتر محمول اجنبي واستبدالها
بكمبيوترات من صناعة صينية. الغت
الصين استخدام الانظمة الاجنبية
يوجد فائزون. يعتبر تسليح الغرب
لاوكرانيا دخولا غير معلن للحرب
فان رأى بوتين انه معلن عندها
فلنقرأ على العالم السلام في
انتشرت هذه الاوبئة في ظل الحروب
النووية الويل لعالم من حرب قد
روسيا على اوكرانيا فهل يتم
تصعيد الخلافات وتندلع حرب بين
اذا لجأ بوتين الى الصواريخ
الباليستية النووية الاسرع من
روسي قاس ايضا. وقد يكون الدولار
العملة الامريكية اول الضحايا
عاما الماضية. فامريكا بعيدة
خمسة الاف ميل وخسارتها اقل الا
تكون ساقك بين فكيه في وصفه
لمفاوضات كييف مع موسكو. العداء
برد قارص وجوع وقحط وخوف ورعب
وانتشار الامراض والاوبئة التي
شأنه ان يذكرنا بحرب العصابات
حرب الانصار التي وقعت في
ان يخسر بها في النهاية حيث يمكن
ان جيشه في احتلال مكلف وغير مجد
في اوكرانيا حتى ان عداء موسكو
للندن قد تجاوز اهالي واشنطن
في هذه الحرب سواء كانت ضيقة او
موسعة هي القارة الاوروبية التي
مائة وثلاثين دولارا. العقوبات
الامريكية تستهدف تدمير اقتصاد
توترات الحرب الباردة. وقررتا
مؤخرا التخلي عن سياسة مسك العصا
تدق وان كان البعض يأمل بان تبقى
نافذة الحل الدبلوماسي مفتوحة
المانيا حيث اجتمعا مع ممثلي
اكثر من اربعين دولة قبول الحرب
العالمية وتاخذ العبرة من روسيا
واليابان وعقوبات امريكا معهم.
والاقتصادية الراسخة منذ مائة
عام على الاقل. سويسرا المحايدة
على اهبة الاستعداد بوتين لن
يفعل هذا الخيار الا في حال
روسيا بالكامل في غضون بضعة اشهر
ولكن هذه العقوبات لن تمر دون رد
واكدت حكومتها ان القناة ممر
عالمي يجب ان يظل محايد. اسعار
هذه الحرب بالشروط التي يريدها
بل توجد في الواقع عدة طرق يمكن
موسكو اليابان من انها ستضطر الى
اتخاذ اجراءات انتقامية اذا تم
الطرفين؟ السيناريو المتوقع
غربيا. بوتين لن يتمكن من كسب
مصر عدم التجاوب مع طلبات
امريكية باغلاق قناة السويس.
توسيع المناورات البحرية
الامريكية اليابانية على الحدود
وهدد كل طرف بالضرب بالنووي وهذه
العداوة هي نتيجة بارزة لحرب
النفط ارتفعت في الاسواق
العالمية ووصل سعر البرميل لنحو
يليه نظام سويفت المالي بالنظر
الى التعاون والتنسيق الروسي
من الوسط. والانضمام الى حلف
الناتو ولحقتهما المانيا بالعودة
البريطاني بوريس جونسون يقول كيف
يمكنك ان تتفاوض مع تمساح عندما
بين روسيا وبريطانيا صعد الى
السطح مجددا بعد الحرب الحالية
الصوت وقرر الضغط على الزر
النووي كحل اخير. رئيس الوزراء
في اوروبا والعالم قلبت كل
المعادلات الامنية والسياسية
الحرب الى اليوم لم يمضي اسبوع
واحد على بداية الاجتياح العسكري
ستجتاح تايوان وكوريا الشمالية
ستهاجم جارتها الجنوبية
خرجت عن حيادها وانضمت الى
العقوبات الغربية المفروضة على
التدخل من الخارج فيما يحدث في
اوكرانيا واظهار تهديدات غير
اعدائه. دعونا نلقي نظرة على
السيناريو الاساسي الذي حدث خلال
التقارير الى تلويحه باستخدام
اسلحة الردع النووية التي جعلها
يحكمون العالم. لكن بالعودة
لاحتمال انتصار روسيا عندها
بالاشتراك مع الصين وسيصبح اصحاب
العيون الضيقة مع الدب الروسي من
امريكا مهاجمة الصين باي طريقة
كانت. لا يجب اغفال او اهمال
زيارة وزيرا والخارجية
الامريكيين الى كييف ومن ثم الى
وحلفائها سيجتمعون شهريا لمساعدة
كييف عسكريا. الحشد الغربي
الحرب العالمية النووية يا سادة.
الصين يبدو انها تستعد للحرب
مقبولة عليهم ان يعلموا ان ردنا
سيكون سريعا وصاعقا. وتشير
سيناريو خسارة روسيا. بعد اجتماع
امني استضافته قاعدة العسكرية
لم تقف مع حليفتها اوكرانيا كما
ينبغي وتركتها لتلقى مصيرها.
الصيني والاستعدادات المسبقة في
هذا الاطار. احد اكبر الخاسرين
بوتين اكد تحذيره مرات عديدة
وقال اذا كان هناك من يعتزم
موسكو لحربها. لكن هناك تلويح
روسي يؤكده بوتين مرارا وتكرارا
استمتعت بالامن والاستقرار
والرخاء الاقتصادي طوال الثمانين
الى اسرائيل من اجل فلسطين ولن
يثق بامريكا بل ولن تثق اي دولة
الى التسليح وبناء جيش قوي.
وربما رؤوس نووية. بينما اعلنت
روسيا. اما فنلندا والسويد
اللتان تجنبتا بالكامل الدخول في
للانطلاق في هذه الرحلة القصيرة.
سيناريو انتصار روسيا. الحقيقة
الروسي لاوكرانيا ومع ذلك حدثت
تغييرات استراتيجية غير مسبوقة
الخسارة عندها لن يكون لديه ما
يخسره. وسيجعلها عليه وعلى
دول العالم وسينقضون على حلفاء
امريكا كل في منطقته. فالصين
واحد كل من الصين وكوريا
الشمالية وايران والجزائر
الدول التي تمتلك ثأرا مع امريكا
وهناك ستظهر مع روسيا في حلف
باستخدام السلاح النووي ويحذر من
خطر اندلاع حرب عالمية ثالثة.
الشرقية لروسيا. وعند انتصار
روسيا سيجتمع الحلف الاوراسي وكل
العسكري والمساعد لدعم اوكرانيا
ستكون احد الاسباب وراء خسارة
الامريكية في المانيا وشاركت فيه
نحو اربعين دولة. علما ان واشنطن
واليابان. وسيلتف العرب حول
روسيا لفقدان الثقة بامريكا التي
ستعود مولدافيا الى الواجهة بعد
تطور الاحداث في المنطقة تمدد
واوكرانيا. روسيا لن تكتفي
بمولدافيا ففي اقصى الشرق حذرت
والعراق وقد تنضم اليهم
افغانستان وكل من ينتظر ذلك من
اخرى في العالم بالامريكان ولا
بقراراتها. وقد الكثير من دول
حلف الناتو لينضموا الى حلف
روسيا بحثا عن الطرف الاقوى
النزاع في اوكرانيا قد يطال جميع
الدول الحدودية مع روسيا
وسيلجأ العالم باكمله الى روسيا
التي ستتولى قيادة العالم
المرة لدى الغرب ان بوتين قد
ينتصر في اوكرانيا وتداعيات ذلك
انتصر بوتين? كيف سيكون وجه
العالم الجديد? دعونا نخبركم في
بوتين الاسلحة النووية على اهبة
الاستعداد. ويقول لن استخدمها
سيحدث ان خسرت روسيا ايضا?
اربطوا احزمة الامان واستعدوا
الاكبر خصوصا في المنطقة
العربية. فالعرب حينها سيلتفتون
ستكون كارثية عليهم. عندما تنتصر
روسيا ستكون امريكا الخاسر
اقتربت.
يخلف له وعد بعكس الامريكان في
وعودهم مع اوكرانيا. وماذا لو
دقائق هذا الفيديو ماذا سيحصل في
حال انتصرت روسيا? وما الذي
وسوريا واليمن وافغانستان. ولكن
دعونا نعود قليلا للوراء. ماذا
الضحايا المدنيون. ففي كل حرب
يوجد ضحايا وهنا لا ننسى ضحايا
وجودي. هل سيستخدمون النووي ويفي
بوتين وعده. واظن ان بوتين لا
لو وصل الروس لطريق مسدود ووصلت
الحرب ذروتها واحاط بهم تهديد
اهلنا في فلسطين وفي الكثير من
البلدان الاسلامية كالعراق
من التطورات المخيفة والاحداث
المحزنة والمرعب فيها هو وضع
التهديد الذي جمد الدم في عروق
الغربيين. اما الامر حقا فهو
الا في حالة حدوث خطر كبير او في
تهديد وجودي لروسيا. يا لهذا
شهران مرا على الحرب الروسية
الاوكرانية حدثت خلالهما الكثير